Uh,
Nathan is the founder and Executive Director of the nonprofit.
I'm from Driftwood,
which you'll be hearing about today.
Uh,
which is an online archive archive of first person Lgbtq stories.
In 2011,
Mansky completed a four month 50 state story collection tour,
ensuring that,
uh,
I'm from driftwoods stories represented people from all across the country.
The story is on,
I'm from driftwood are used by family counselors as well as educators to aid
them in their work.
Uh,
and I'm from driftwoods newest program,
which is called,
what was it like documents,
stories from Lgbtq elders,
which as you know,
is something that we have also been looking at,
uh,
in the gay colors is understanding how to better serve,
um,
older Lgbtq folks.
Um,
Matthew grew up in Driftwood,
Texas,
hence the name I'm from driftwood where one of his weekly chores was burning
trash in a burn barrel,
which I really want to hear about.
Uh,
he now lives in Brooklyn where he sorts and recycles.
Thank you for saving the planet.
Um,
so Nathan tell us a little bit,
uh,
now that we know a little bit about you.
About I'm from driftwood.
Yeah.
Next month in March is actually going to be our nine year anniversary,
which we're very excited about.
And it started,
the idea came to me from a,
after watching the film milk in 2008 with Sean Penn.
And uh,
there was,
I saw the film on a Wednesday and Thursday morning I was thinking about a
photograph of Harvey Milk and in the photograph he is holding,
he's sitting on the hood of the car in the San Francisco Pride March and he's
holding a big sign and the sign,
all it said was I'm from Woodmere New York.
And I was just thinking about that photo,
uh,
over and over again and asking myself like,
why is Harvey Milk?
Everyone associates him with San Francisco,
this big queer Mecca.
Uh,
but he's not from there.
He,
he's sitting here proclaiming that he's from this town that we're in New York.
So some people might know where it is,
but most people don't know where Woodmere is.
And that really resonated with me because I'm not from Brooklyn or New York.
I'm from Driftwood,
Texas.
And I feel like that message of you're not alone no matter where you are,
um,
would have meant a lot to me.
Growing up in driftwood where my main issue was isolation,
I didn't feel like it or I did feel like I was the only gay person in the world.
Um,
so that message of you're not alone would have meant a lot to me.
So I wanted to,
to take that message out there through storytelling and,
uh,
that at the time I was working in advertising as a copywriter and I was worried
that I wouldn't have time to do this.
And,
uh,
so I had to recap.
I saw milk on Wednesday.
I thought of the idea on Thursday.
Friday I went into my job and I was laid off.
So I suddenly had all the time in the world to,
uh,
you know,
it was late 2008 height of the recession.
Um,
so there was little chance to get a new job right away.
So I put everything I had into it.
Told all my friends,
everyone rallied around me and,
um,
helped launch three months after thinking of the idea and March,
2009.
So yeah,
that's how,
how it came to be.
They're cool often from photograph.
Um,
so tell us a little bit about what I'm from driftwood seeks to do.
What is the project about?
Uh,
it at its core,
it's about sending that message if you are not alone,
uh,
through storytelling.
And something really interesting happened,
uh,
early on we started as just written stories so anyone could write a story and
still can,
uh,
and submit their written story.
And,
um,
but it started really to help queer youth and smaller towns.
That was my singular focus.
And after launching the site,
we started getting all this feedback from people letting us know what this story
is meant to them.
And it wasn't just queer youth in small towns.
It was,
uh,
people here in Manhattan.
It was people all over the country and the world,
uh,
letting us know that just by re hearing stories from other people,
whether they connected with it or not,
uh,
made them more empathetic to other issues.
Um,
and then of course,
people did read stories that they related to and it helped them realize I'm not
alone.
And there were two pieces of feedback that we got very early on,
which made us realize that we were on the right track.
Uh,
one was from a gay teenager who said,
uh,
seeing these stories made him realize that he's not alone and that they
literally saved his life just by realizing that,
you know,
wherever he was from,
that there are other people like the hidden out there.
Uh,
the other one was from somebody who was almost 60,
and he said,
I thought I was the only one.
I'm not,
and I just came out this past Christmas,
uh,
at the age of 60.
So once we realized that we were making an impact across the entire spectrum,
we sort of broadened our reach.
Uh,
but still with that message of you're not alone.
Um,
but no matter who you are,
where you are,
what age you are.
Um,
so,
so yeah,
that's,
that's really,
you know,
what,
what we are still,
uh,
but with a broader message.
So
that's really interesting.
So what,
you spoke a little bit about the impact that it's had on a couple of
individuals,
but can you speak broadly more broadly about the impact that you feel this
particular,
the evolution of this Lgbtq Story Archive has had on your members readership
viewership?
Yeah,
we,
I had an intern a few years ago and I was still in this mindset of,
especially since we're nonprofit,
so we have to apply for funding and all that fun stuff.
And,
uh,
constantly we're having to tell people why we're doing what we're doing is so
important and why.
And
it was frustrating and a little scary.
I was like,
I can't answer this succinctly.
You know,
I like wash the story,
you'll get it,
but that's not an acceptable answer on a grant application.
Uh,
so I,
I gave a this intern,
this task of researching,
like why stories are so powerful and why they increase empathy that we knew they
did.
We have the feedback to support it,
but I didn't understand why.
And I kept like,
I felt like I was just grasping for Aaron.
I couldn't sink my teeth into an,
and,
uh,
what he came back with,
um,
was,
was science of course.
So it was,
uh,
there's something called mirror neurons and everyone's brain and whenever you
tell a story,
you're activating a mirror neurons and that person's brain.
So on a very microscopic level,
they are experiencing the same thing that you experienced.
So if I tell you a story and let's just say our lives are completely different,
and I tell you the story about what it's like to grow up gay and Driftwood,
and I tell a story well,
and uh,
then I'm activating those mirror neurons in your brain so that,
you know,
whenever you,
you hear a story like,
oh,
I,
I get it.
I feel you,
you know,
I'm,
I'm in your shoes.
That's the reason for that is those mirror neurons.
So,
uh,
since then we have focused more on telling stories.
Well,
so every single story that we collect and share,
uh,
we make sure that there is a story arc.
There's a beginning,
middle,
and end.
There's a conflict and a resolution and all these traditional storytelling,
uh,
components that make a story so that we can activate those mirror neurons.
So we're basically trying to control mines.
Just a simple,
simple task.
Yeah.
Nothing,
nothing difficult.
Building empathy in the world,
changing people's minds about things.
No,
no big deal.
Um,
so how did the development of I'm from driftwood go,
did it grow very,
very quickly?
Were you surprised by the growth or,
um,
has it developed sort of as a slow burn over the time that you've been going?
It was a little bit of a rollercoaster.
Uh,
we,
we launched just as a website,
um,
and I didn't really have this grand vision of what it could become at the time.
I just wanted to start collecting and sharing stories.
Uh,
about a week after launching,
uh,
I was just spending all my time emailing this is 2008,
2000 or 2009,
like blow everyone had a blog at that time.
Just,
it was a blog heavy time on the internet.
And,
uh,
there were a lot of LGBT blogs and I was just emailing every,
Lgbtq blog that I could find.
And a lot of them started picking it up and sharing it.
And we just caught a wave of stories.
And soon after that,
um,
I had a friend in Philadelphia,
his name is Mark [inaudible] and I had this idea of a little PR video I wanted
to do in New York.
I was going to walk around the city with a whiteboard and happy we'll right
where they're from just to like get the idea out there again.
And another nod to that photograph of Harvey Milk.
And he would visit New York frequently.
And I told them this idea and he was like,
Oh,
I'm into it.
Um,
but how about we have people tell you a story and I'll film it and edit it.
And I was resistant to it.
I was like,
that's not my idea.
My idea was this PR video that I want to like send out,
like to help me in these,
this outreach,
you know?
And uh,
but he was like,
I'm not interested in that.
Like this,
you know?
So there was a little,
you know,
and I was,
okay,
let's do some,
some,
I dunno,
video stories.
And he came to New York,
we filmed two of them.
And,
uh,
they not only were a hit,
they are now the focus.
What I'm from,
just what it is today,
which are these weekly videos,
stories,
uh,
that we,
that we publish every Wednesday.
So,
um,
it was all because of Marquez.
Who's,
who's now a board member.
I was like,
oh,
you have really good ideas.
And a,
so actually,
do you want to watch a video story?
Yeah,
yeah,
let's do it.
So we've got a couple of videos here for,
for you to see.
So let me make sure my click,
there we go.
Hi,
my name is not buyer Schmidt.
I'm from kinds when New Jersey and when I was 15 years old,
I was,
um,
all my family computer talking on AOL chat rooms and just to meet people and
meet other guys.
And you know,
unbeknownst to rest of my family,
I'm in the mail from Elle Chat Room and,
uh,
I'm talking to this guy and he's,
you know,
back in the day you maybe got one picture from somebody,
like it took like five minutes for one picture to upload,
so you had to like take what you can get 15,
he's probably like in his thirties,
and yet no one knows my age.
I'm telling you I'm older,
but,
um,
so I sky's very eager to meet me and very,
you know,
just kind of giving me negative vibes.
But I'm desperate to meet somebody.
I want to just have a connection with somebody and you know,
um,
so I just have a really weird feeling about him.
So when I go to,
um,
before I go to meet him,
I literally have to like sneak out my parents house.
Um,
and,
um,
I take a kitchen knife with me just to like be safe.
And I thought that would like,
it was one of those old like eighties would handle it.
Like,
you know,
kitchen knives.
I wouldn't like cut a carrot,
but I thought it would kill somebody.
So I take the kitchen knife,
go back to my room and I sneak out my first story window,
hopped to the ground and I walk about a half mile to this river near my parents'
house.
Told the guy when I was wearing,
and he,
we agreed on the time to meet and no cell phones.
So we have to tell them,
you know,
I'll meet you at this time and you just go down there and wait.
So he picks me up and we drive to this like I think one of the parking lots
along the river and it's dark and you know,
I'm not really into him,
but he's like,
he's at hideous but just not really into him.
And you know,
he's in the May and you know,
I've already come all this way and you know,
so I feel obligated to do something.
So I ended up,
you know,
fully around the guy and I was a little nervous,
but um,
ends that,
that like,
you know,
we end up falling around maybe 10 minutes and afterwards I like get out of the
car immediately and I just start heading home.
I don't know if it was that night or the next night,
but I'm like,
I'm online again and I get an email from him saying like,
you know,
it was nice to meet you.
I'm just making a nice guy and you know,
you forgot your knife and my car.
And I just like was like mortified.
But you know,
also,
um,
they don't really care because I was petrified at the time and you know,
glad I brought it.
So flash forward to a few months later,
I'm back in south jersey,
male for male chatting with people and I've been chatting with this one guy for
a while.
One kid for a while,
I remember his name,
screen name was keg killer and I was blue swoosh,
um,
81 as my birthday and I'm like,
he was Swiss shit.
But,
um,
I ended up and we tried it for awhile and I had a feeling he was legit and real
and my blue,
we chatted about stuff.
I knew he was my age live nearby.
I really wanted to meet him,
but he did not want to meet me.
He was very skeptical about it,
very scared about it.
But he asked to actually dropped where he worked randomly in conversation one
time.
So,
um,
I,
it was a movie theater,
so I asked my friend Liz to go to the movies with me and it was the glossy go
ball hunting and I think it was like a 96,
97 at this time point.
And um,
I knew was that his movie theater.
So I just randomly went there one night to go see it.
And when I got there,
the guy taking my ticket,
like it resembled him,
I resembled his stats,
remember what his,
I was like,
okay,
that's him.
That's him.
So we went to the movie,
got inside of the movie and like halfway through the movie I come back out and I
make sure I buy,
like I have some candy.
I make sure I make eye contact with him and made sure that like we have some
sort of interaction,
not like talking about,
I made sure he saw me the next night or the night after.
I'm online again,
hope and I'll sign on so I can tell him I went to his work and he ends up
signing on and I am chatting with him.
I'm like,
Hey,
you know,
I went to your work.
I think I follow you.
I was burying this.
I said hi to you.
And he remembered me and um,
was willing to meet me now.
So we ended up meeting like that night or night after.
I can't exactly remember,
but um,
you know,
from then on we were like instant friends and we had this like,
um,
it was my first gay friend ever.
I made.
And uh,
we have so much in common.
He lived right near me.
He was in high school too.
And,
you know,
I had like my first gay friend that I can do anything with and we ended up just
like being
going to the city and experiencing everything together for the next 10 years.
And it was like something that I didn't know I needed until I had it.
When I found Jeff,
I was able to be myself,
be honest,
be um,
just be me.
When I was 15,
I had a,
I had to find people online because in 1996,
there wasn't anything else.
But like,
you know,
I think today I think it's important to have safe spaces were,
um,
young queer youth can go meet other people like them.
So we're not putting themselves in these weird predicaments.
Like I was meeting a complete stranger down by the river with a knife.
That's not like,
it's funny now to think about it,
but like,
it's also really scary and,
um,
I don't want anybody to be in that position,
you know.
So I think anybody who's young in the closet or you know,
not even in the closet,
but it's still needs allies,
they need to find safe spaces near them.
You need that you meet people like you going through the same thing as you,
so you can like,
you know,
make mistakes with them,
learn from their mistakes and like,
you know,
and help each other out.
It's important.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm not as good at this clicker thing I was going to be.
So,
um,
can you tell us a little bit about this video and why you decided to include it
in today's talk?
We have a others as well,
so I've
got more to come.
Yeah.
So,
um,
early on I knew that I didn't want to or I knew a couple of things.
One is I wanted to make sure that this was not a coming out story site and it
was very important to me to,
to share stories that capture the queer experience as opposed to this one moment
in everyone's life.
Um,
and so the only prompt that I give the storytellers is to share a story from
your life,
this meaningful to you involving Ubn Lgbtq and some storytellers.
You're like,
that's not very good direction.
Like,
I intentionally leave it very open.
I don't want to guide you down any sort of story or any direction that might not
be a meaningful,
your most meaningful stories.
So,
um,
we have a long list of thought starter questions to help people kind of think of
what story they want to share.
Um,
but,
so this story was,
uh,
you know,
we asked Matt to think of a story and,
uh,
you know,
the,
the processes we emailed back and forth,
we send,
send the storyteller link,
uh,
with a thought starter questions and a little form for them to just get in
storytelling mode,
um,
to set the stage of what it's like.
So they,
they understand that it's not a question and answer interview.
It's not like a back and forth.
It's just a sharing their story with me.
And,
uh,
so this was just a story that stuck out a lot to Matt.
And,
uh,
so that's really,
you know,
so he shared it and you know,
we loved it.
And,
uh,
and,
and actually that reminds me of another really valuable learning experience that
I had a very early on.
It was about probably three weeks after launching the website.
So it was very new and I was very inexperienced and very protective of I'm from
Driftwood,
you know,
it's like,
it has to be perfect and you know,
all this stuff.
And uh,
but the only guidelines I had were it has to be a story and asked to be like
grammatically correct.
Like it was very,
very loose,
you know,
so I would like scan the stories and make little,
grammar and spelling,
uh,
fixes.
But if it's a story,
um,
I would publish it.
So I received one story and this is a written story and the truth is I just
didn't connect with it.
Uh,
whatever it was,
I just didn't like,
I wasn't feeling it.
And this was,
you know,
again,
at a time where I was,
I was wanting to put this,
I'm from trips was best face forward.
And so I started,
I started a draft of an email to the storyteller explaining,
you know,
thank you for submitting,
maybe rework it or send another one.
And I couldn't articulate why I didn't want to publish it.
And then I started feeling bad.
I'm like,
what am I going to say it?
Like,
I don't like your story.
sorry,
like,
who am I to say that?
So,
um,
so I was like,
oh,
whatever.
I'm just going to publish it.
So I published it and one of the very first comments said,
this is the best story I've read on the site.
And I'm so glad that I learned that early on because like,
the reason it didn't connect with me is because I didn't need it to my,
I have my life and my experiences and my history and that story.
I just,
I didn't need that story,
but other people did.
So it,
it allowed to really remove myself and my personal experiences from I'm from
driftwood.
And,
uh,
so whenever people come up with a story like Matt,
that was a meaningful story to him.
And,
and it just so happens that I connect with it because I was definitely on those
AOL in fort m chat rooms also.
But,
uh,
but that's,
that's why I'm very,
I try to be hands off in terms of helping people think of their stories.
Uh,
and some people have mini stories that they're thinking about and then we'll
talk to them and,
and help them,
you know,
uh,
develop,
develop the more,
so
yeah,
it's,
I think it's really fascinating and an archive like this,
the diversity of experience that you find.
Um,
so I would encourage everybody to go and take a look at the site which has this
video archive and you can really find an enormous number of different kinds of
stories from people with very,
very wide ranging,
uh,
experiences of identifying as Lgbtq at various,
you know,
in,
in various stages of their journey throughout life.
Um,
but I'm curious also if you saw some recurring themes,
did you have certain things that kept circling up for you that even as you were
stepping away from being personally invested in or connecting with every story?
Um,
did you,
did you find that interesting things were popping up over and over again?
Not generally at first.
Uh,
and it actually leads me to talking about the stories tore because at first we
were collecting video stories from people.
Uh,
we had no money.
We had an organization that was just like doing what we could.
So we had to do what was easiest,
which was collect stories and New York and Philadelphia where at Marquee slips
and the store.
The good thing about New York and Philly is that they're such international,
uh,
cities.
So people are from everywhere here in New York.
Uh,
so it was good because we were getting some diverse stories,
but I felt like we were cheating a little bit,
uh,
because all the people here decided to move here.
And that is a different kind of person that people who decide to stay in their
hometowns.
So that was where the idea of the 50 state stories where it came from.
I was like,
we're not getting,
you know,
we're,
we're doing a good job of getting diverse stories,
but we need to really get out there.
And,
uh,
so I,
I pitched the idea to Marquees and uh,
he was like,
he had a nice cushy job,
you know,
in Philly.
And of course I'm scrambling to do what I can to turn this into an organization.
And so I'm like,
let's go to all 50 states,
you know,
and he's like,
he's like,
how is that possible?
Like,
let's do like a a five day,
three city tour in the northeast,
you know,
let's start there,
build some interest.
And I was like,
no,
no one's going to care about a three city tour and over five days we have to do
it big and has to be,
you know,
I'm from driftwoods 50 state stories where it has to be,
stories from all over the country.
And
about six months later,
uh,
and a lot of convincing and conversations,
um,
he,
we decided to do it and I bought a van,
mapped it all out.
And you did it by vehicle?
We drove,
we flew to Alaska and Hawaii.
Yeah,
we thought about getting a duck vans so we could drive to Hawaii.
But no.
Um,
so yeah,
we,
we drove to all 48 states and then flew to Hawaii from Hawaii to Alaska then,
yeah,
back to the 48 states and it took over four months.
And,
uh,
so,
to answer your question,
that was when we noticed a trend because it was,
I,
I guess there's a trend I guess,
of me setting rules for myself,
but I was like,
I don't want to seek out specific stories.
If we are in Laramie,
Wyoming,
I don't want to seek out and not shepard story.
If we're in the south,
I don't want to seek out,
uh,
religious,
stories.
If we're in Utah.
I don't want to seek out Mormon stories.
I just like wanted the stories to happen and stick to our guns and say whatever
story you want to share.
And I'm glad we did that because that is the best way to notice a trend of,
you know,
without,
uh,
Swain at any certain way.
And,
uh,
so it,
it,
and the trend was something that I didn't predict.
It was a,
we did presentations like story sharing events at colleges and universities.
And whenever I did,
I would ask people,
they're like,
what does it like being Lgbtq here and,
uh,
in Kansas,
you know,
and the answers consistently were the smaller the town,
the more the youth or community wanted to challenge the perception of the rest
of the country about their small town.
And they're like,
just because we're in a small town doesn't mean we're backwards.
Idiots.
Like,
you know,
knuckle draggers,
like were I,
my family is supportive of me.
My,
you know,
my school,
I'm out of school.
Like they were really challenging this perception of Kansas or wherever we were
being this,
you know,
terrible small town and they're like,
it's not that way.
Like we don't have protections.
We,
they were very honest and real about it,
but they were like,
just,
you know,
everyone thinks that they hear I'm from Kansas and they think,
oh,
it must be so terrible.
And there are rooms for improvement,
but it's not this terrible place to be.
And,
uh,
then the opposite was true in the big cities,
the same but opposite.
So it was,
we were in,
uh,
West Hollywood,
at the La Center.
Um,
and it's west Hollywood,
like the gay us of the gay,
you know,
and,
uh,
all these,
there was probably 18 to,
or maybe even 16 to 24,
a youth group had a meeting and we shared stories and I almost didn't even ask
because this is beautiful.
Like there's so much money behind it and their center and it was new and
renovated.
And,
uh,
but I was like,
I shouldn't ask.
I was like,
what's it like being,
you know,
Lgbtq here in West Hollywood,
and all their hands shot up.
And they're like,
just because we're in west Hollywood doesn't mean it's easy.
And I don't live in West Hollywood.
I live with my parents.
They,
I had to sneak out to be here.
They don't know I'm gay.
My friend was kicked out.
So it was the same idea of challenging the perception of what the world sees
them as,
um,
and kind of turning that on its head.
And basically everyone was saying,
we're unique.
We're,
we're,
there's not a broad stroke that you can paint for our town or city.
And,
um,
but they all wanted,
you know,
it was like pay attention to us,
to us,
not our town or city.
So that was,
uh,
the biggest trend I saw a on this story tour.
That's really good to hear.
I'm glad that that was the trend and not something,
you know,
worse or more difficult.
Yeah.
Good to hear that people were challenging,
able to challenge their perceptions of their small towns as someone who grew up
in a relatively small town in the middle of New Mexico,
which at the time with,
um,
probably also a place in which people would imagine it being not particularly
LGBTQ friendly.
Um,
I actually didn't want to challenge that perception so much cause I think that
at the time it was personal,
a pretty difficult place to grow up.
But I,
I can understand the impetus is thrive Tryon,
um,
you know,
give a real understanding for folks who don't live there of what it's actually
like to be from that place as an LGBTQ person.
So,
yeah.
Yeah.
I feel like there's a balance.
Like people are like,
yeah,
like there's pride.
It's like,
I'm from here.
I like it.
I love it.
There's an issue is,
but hey,
it's not,
you know,
there's,
it's not all the way one or the other.
There is a balance.
And,
um,
yeah,
that's great.
Um,
at what point did you start to have an understanding of,
um,
where you needed to broaden out your demographics?
So you were talking in particular about looking at the stories of older Lgbtq
folks who are,
is often a part of our,
our community that can be either not properly cared for,
not properly highlighted or sometimes even a silenced and,
and a variety of ways.
So I'm using that as an example,
sort of,
where was the fork in the road where you realized that that broadening
demographics would be really helpful?
Pretty early on,
we knew that we wanted to,
um,
make sure that the stories represented the diversity of the community,
which is,
I mean,
there's no community more diverse than the LGBT community because we're every,
every part of every community.
So,
uh,
it was always a focus,
but,
um,
it was,
it wasn't until we would say the process is we help storytellers come up with a
single story to share from their life.
And what would happen whenever we would get a story from somebody who's older is
that we would,
you know,
work with them on the phone and figure out a single story and we would show up
to film and,
you know,
let's say for example,
the story is about,
you know,
they fell in love at age 50,
but then we show up with cameras and they're like,
when I was 14 and I was like,
what?
Like wait,
we're looking at my notes late,
uh,
late,
listen.
And they try to cram in their entire life into this story.
And we,
and we try to keep,
the video is about five,
five to six minutes because we want to make sure people watch them.
And if,
if we upload a 25 minute video,
like it's unlikely people are gonna Watch the whole thing.
So,
uh,
there's this balance of needing to have shareable and viewable content while,
you know,
making sure that we respect the storyteller and the story they want to share.
So with elders,
we were just like,
then we felt bad because we'd publish their story and they're like,
what about this and this and this.
Then I talked about and we're like,
it's just,
you know,
it was too long.
We don't think people would watch it.
So they would be a little sad by that and we feel like we let them down.
So we wanted to come up with a way to kind of have this compromise of like,
what can we do to,
and also elders have no one in the community ever will have see as much history
and change in the community as our elders right now.
They have been arrested for dancing with people at the same gender and now they
can marry people with the same gender and that won't exist in 20 years.
And it didn't exist 20 years ago.
And,
uh,
so it's,
we also knew the importance and value of documenting and preserving their
history.
Um,
so we came up with this new program called,
what was it like an,
a specifically stories of Lgbtq elders.
And,
uh,
the way that program works is that we,
instead of having them share one story,
uh,
we helped them figure out six to eight individual stories in their life.
So it's still,
every story has an arc.
Every story has an individual conflict and resolution.
Uh,
so then we can share them individually.
but it also gives them the opportunity to share their whole life,
but still through individual stories.
So,
uh,
we launched that about a year and a half ago and it's,
it's been incredible.
Um,
it's the,
the content has,
I mean,
we,
we talk a lot like,
you know,
behind the scenes.
But,
you know,
even Damian,
my,
my colleague and the videographer and editor,
he says,
um,
the stories from elders or they're just better.
I mean,
because they have so much,
there's so,
such different history and,
you know,
younger people have fewer stories to choose from.
So,
um,
it's,
it's really been just an incredible,
um,
new program that we're happy with.
And we actually,
we have a story from an elder if we're ready to watch.
Yes.
It's,
we're gonna have to skip Alexis.
Yeah.
Okay.
So give me just one second to do my clicker.
There we go.
It was,
here it is.
Right.
Um,
in 1997 give or take a year or two,
I was working out on fire island,
a barrier island
off of long island.
And I worked at this little restaurant called El hot spot.
It was a Mexican restaurant with a generic name breaths.
Again,
no Mexican name.
And I told that I could wear anything I wanted and in fact they encourage me to
dress up,
be myself.
I was wearing to church dresses,
sort of what hats,
sometimes all different kinds of wigs.
And um,
I didn't know much about makeup,
but I had some girlfriends that started to help me with the makeup and stuff.
I was given this creative freedom.
I had basically lived as a gay man and,
um,
parole hadn't emerged yet and so I was wearing,
I just tried to put together things that I could find.
They had a lot of,
uh,
I was wearing,
they would have a lot of their old drag queens out on the island would retire
and they're dragging.
They would,
they would put it up at,
at a yard sales and I would go shopping.
That's where I did my shopping in the beginning,
cause I dare not go to any store,
the buy women's clothing.
And so I was,
uh,
getting ready to come into the city and I was going to go through my whole
routine,
put on my back into my male clothing and get ready to come back.
Simple.
I've done it a thousand times and at that time I couldn't get it together.
I couldn't change my clothes and I couldn't get out of my drag to go back into
the city.
And I felt so schizophrenia [inaudible] Aye,
Aye.
And I started talking to myself.
I said,
okay,
now Pearl,
come on off it.
Uh,
or I might've even talked to Ken.
I said,
okay,
chop chop,
let's get it together.
Let's get on that boat,
take off these clothes.
And it was like Pearl came out of me and said,
I'm not taking them off.
It was like,
I said,
what?
As he said,
I'm not taking this dress off and I'm holding a conversation with myself.
I said,
of course you are.
we can't go.
And so I went up to the ice palace and I remember talking to one of the,
uh,
one of the entertainers,
they aren't,
I said,
I'm going back into the city just like this.
And he said,
no,
Pearl,
you got to take it off because you could be beat up or you could be,
I said,
Pearl won't take,
let me take the drag along.
So I know they probably said,
just tells,
been drawing a little too many drugs.
So I ran home,
got my bag,
got my stuff and I got on the boat.
It was the most surreal trip across the bay from Cherry Grove back to save hill.
And I'm on the way in and people are looking and,
um,
and I looked just like what I am.
And I go in and I remember walking through Penn station and I'm in a flowing
something people.
And when I looked like in my weight,
you know how you walk past somebody and if you look back real quick in your
weight,
there's all these people,
they're angry.
Like what?
And I get on the subway and I catch the train on back down this way.
Now it's getting ready to just throw everything out that I thought I was a gay
black man living with HIV.
And now this new new something has emerged that was peaking out all the time pro
with there.
She didn't have a name,
but she was there.
Everything up to this point had led to me,
uh,
being true to myself as a transgender woman.
And I,
at that point,
I had no idea what that meant because for the next 16 years it was,
and it still continue.
Today.
It's,
it's been a journey and I wouldn't trade it
so
clearly.
Um,
you know,
a lot of these stories,
again,
uh,
it's just really wonderful being able to see each of these stories on the
archive.
It's,
it's such an incredible experience that sort of jumped into other people's
lives.
Um,
all those mirror neurons getting fired up.
but I'm curious,
it's actually leads us really nicely into a part of what you came here to talk
about,
which was,
um,
having all of this be a digital platform and have it be an internet based,
particularly when we're talking about Lgbtq elders who may have told stories,
um,
prior to this becoming an easy platform to access in very different ways.
So I'm curious how you see that playing in an influencing this project sort of
as a,
at,
at its core.
Yeah.
I mean,
it simply wouldn't exist if it,
if we weren't in the Internet age right now and,
uh,
without youtube and ways to share all these stories because it's,
our focus has always been on getting these stories out to,
uh,
a home in,
you know,
Idaho somewhere.
Like it's,
uh,
that's the,
that's what makes [inaudible] special I think is it's accessibility,
uh,
freely accessible to anyone with an internet connection.
And,
uh,
that's,
it's,
that's what's special about it.
I mean,
we look at our analytics and this,
the,
uh,
most of our views do come from the bigger states,
but,
uh,
just knowing that they'd been seen from every country in the world and,
it,
it wouldn't own,
I can't understate it,
it wouldn't exist without a,
where we are today with the Internet.
Um,
so it's,
it's,
the name itself is like its,
you know,
Talon focused,
geography focused.
It's um,
you know,
really all about getting our stories out there.
Um,
that said,
we,
yeah,
there is an element of,
um,
yeah,
like I dunno,
like it becomes a little bit impersonal for,
especially for me because I spend so much time on just like a computer sharing
these stories and it's becomes so digital that it loses a little bit of heart
sometimes.
Um,
and I can't tell if that's just me because it's my job,
uh,
or uh,
or what,
but because of that,
we started having more community events where we screen stories and public
places and me have storyteller spotlights.
So Pearl for example,
was one of our first featured storyteller spotlights where we screen a few of
her stories and she's there with a moderator and there's questions from the
audience.
So,
you know,
you see these stories and then you can actually ask the storyteller questions.
So it kind of takes it offline.
Uh,
so as much as we're focusing on online,
uh,
we're now,
I think maybe is humans in general.
Like we've,
we've been so focused on online and digital and phones now we're like,
wait,
I missed this,
like personal connection.
And we're kind of like correcting that a little bit.
Um,
so I,
I,
I'm glad that we now have these ways of experiencing.
I'm from driftwood offline.
So yeah,
that's really the,
having the compliment is really cool.
Um,
so online storytelling,
um,
clearly doesn't have,
uh,
a very long history,
certainly not in comparison to storytelling more broadly,
but,
um,
so we don't have a ton of precedent too though off,
but I'm curious as somebody who is involved on a daily basis,
um,
in curating LGBTQ stories in the online space,
do you have sense for how online storytelling,
particularly around Lgbtq stories is going to develop over the next five,
10 years?
Like what,
what do you see coming up for online storytelling?
I think,
and I think just generally it's going to become decentralized and,
uh,
we're actually trying to put together a,
a youth committee,
uh,
to help us figure out if,
cause nine years is a long time for the Internet.
Like it so much has changed.
You know,
Instagram didn't exist when we started.
So,
uh,
what I want to figure out is what I'm from trips,
what it would look like today if it started,
if it started today,
it would probably not be a centralized website.
Uh,
it would be more of,
I mean a Hashtag or something and it's not all living on one place.
It's everywhere.
Uh,
and you can look at,
you know,
like the,
the me too movement that is not a centralized,
it's storytelling and it's a singular theme and it's everywhere.
There's not a single place to go there.
So I think that,
uh,
I think,
yeah,
it,
storytelling is going to become a decentralized,
I guess.
Is it maybe a,
a dry answer,
but I think that's like where it's going.
Um,
just the,
the Internet in general is less,
you look at blogs now,
like they just,
they're not as many blogs.
Like people don't go to places and I'm like,
bookmarks and stuff.
It's now just what you read on Instagram or Facebook or Twitter,
but it's all kind of,
I feel like everything's been taken and chicken up and just like thrown out
there.
So I think it's going to be similar for storytelling.
Just saying,
how do you find,
um,
sort of navigating that space,
knowing that it's become becoming decentralized and clearly there are lots of
options for where folks can go to find LGBTQ stories.
So,
um,
do you find it a challenge to try and get,
I'm from Driftwood,
uh,
into a unique enough space that it's still kind of like holding its own and what
can be just a competitive,
as you say,
decentralized space on the Internet?
Yeah,
it's,
the challenge for us is,
you know,
we're trying to plan five years in advance in 10 years in advance.
And looking back,
it's like,
oh my God,
like five years ago,
things change so fast and we're applying for funding for something that we're
planning for like in a couple of years then.
But then if you get the funding,
it's like,
wait,
actually we need to change this because of this.
And it,
it's just a very fast paced environment obviously.
But that's,
that's a good thing.
So it's,
it's,
that's not a complaint.
It's just,
uh,
it,
it is a challenge though.
And I'm just trying to always keep up with it and stay relevant.
Um,
you know,
is a,
a website the way to go or is it,
um,
do we,
you know,
is it,
do we need 22nd video stories?
Like is it,
is it,
you know,
and actually we have been doing,
we've been tracking a youtube has analytics that allows you to monitor the
percentage of the video watched.
And early on we were very focused on less than three minutes.
Like we kind of made it up but also looked did some research and we're like less
than three minutes for a video story.
And then we got a really great story that had to be closer to four minutes and
we're like,
okay,
just this once.
But we compare those analytics and we're like,
look,
the same percentage of people watched it and now we're at,
some of our videos are over seven minutes and the percentage stays the same.
So that just taught us that the story arc is it takes the primary focus and as
long as it's a story,
people watch it for the same amount of time as a percentage of time as they
would for two minute story.
So,
um,
yeah,
I,
I forget how I got there,
but okay.
Oh no,
that's,
that's really interesting.
I think that,
um,
I know that that's not the case for all youtube videos,
right.
Plenty of them.
You sort of drop off in the middle.
Um,
so it's really interesting to hear that that is,
uh,
you know,
that LGBTQ stories are really connecting,
particularly that arc is keeping people engaged.
Um,
over the course.
I'm sure,
you know,
on the keeping up with the technology piece,
I know that as I get older and more crotchety,
um,
it's actually really difficult to keep up with the new technologies that are
coming out.
Um,
and understanding how they work.
Like a s snapchat is just a thing that I just do not understand nor use.
Um,
yes,
it came along with my gray hairs a so I can imagine that that is difficult,
but it's,
it's a really interesting space to be in.
Um,
hmm.
Do you use committee committee?
So,
um,
I know that we had one more video we want to show,
which we certainly can,
but I,
before we jump into getting some questions from the audience and certainly
showing this last video we'd like to,
I just want to make sure that we touch on how groups like ours.
So the gigglers is Google's Lgbtq employee resource group.
Um,
and uh,
how groups like the gigglers as well as other Lgbtq,
um,
community groups or organizations can become involved with a project like this.
Um,
either with the option to contribute or help spread the word,
etc.
Yeah.
There,
there are so many ways.
We a very small organization and we have very big goals of what we're trying to
do and it's just me and Damien.
So,
uh,
we won his share your story.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
from what I've heard is a good process.
It's a learning process.
You learn about storytelling and it's,
it's a,
we come to you to film your story.
Um,
so just reach out to us.
Nathan at,
I'm from [inaudible] dot com and we will like get your story.
If you don't live here,
we can sometimes find videographers,
uh,
in your area.
Um,
but sharing your story is,
there's no better way to get to know more about the organization.
Um,
then sharing your story.
Uh,
we,
we have like community events,
we have volunteer opportunities,
we have this youth committee.
So if you're knowledgeable on uh,
uh,
on all these like new,
like we need help with Instagram and also it's just like time,
like I'm trying to keep Instagram,
uptodate,
you know,
with our stories and photos and,
and it's just,
we need help and guidance.
So a social media ad words,
we have a Google grant and like Edwards is so in depth and it's,
it's,
yeah,
it's way beyond what I am able to do.
So I,
we need help with that.
We need help with anything.
So if basically if you are interested in taking part in volunteering at events
or anything at all with a storytelling organization,
uh,
just reach out to me and we will make sure that you're doing something that you
enjoy.
That's great.
Um,
I think that in the interest of time,
we might open it up now for Q and.
A.
Um,
unless there was anything else that you wanted to on before we
jump into some audience questions.
No,
sounds great.
Okay,
great.
Does anybody have any questions?
Yes.
Jeff it.
Hi,
I'm Mike.
I took a brief look at your website and you know,
from that and from what you've,
what you've shown here,
um,
you,
you highlight for example,
um,
transgender stories,
uh,
gender nonbinary stories.
You talked about,
you,
you showed a story of a community elder.
Um,
though I didn't see a way that particularly access that on your website and it
got me wondering whether you,
whether there are tools there that I just didn't see that allow people to
explore the site from the point of view of various kinds of intersectionality.
Yes.
Uh,
so basically a way to,
uh,
we tag all of our stories.
Uh,
so it's,
uh,
I have like a traffic jam in my mind of like what I want to say.
So,
uh,
we are working on a new tool right now,
which we need help with,
uh,
from a smart developers and coders and you know,
all that stuff that we don't know how to do.
Um,
we're,
we want to create what's currently called a story map and it's a visual
representation of I'm from driftwoods,
so it's literally this globe.
Um,
and uh,
it,
there's a visual representation of every single story that we've collected and
it's interactive,
so you can click on it and it pulls up a preview of the story and you can filter
those by,
uh,
our,
what was it like stories.
You can filter it by transgender stories like sexuality,
gender orientation or gender identity.
And,
uh,
so,
so that is kind of stepping in that direction of making it easier to search and
find the stories that you want.
Um,
the website itself right now is not ideal for that.
You can go to the search bar and type in,
um,
you know,
like New Mexico and all the New Mexico stories will come up,
but it's not,
it's not perfectly there yet.
Uh,
but we,
the story map is my answer for all that because then you can search for anything
and it's you,
it's right there.
You see like this globe and it pulls up all those stories and you can zoom in
and see it's,
it's really cool,
but we have to get it to a place where we can publish it and it's not quite
there yet.
Uh,
and additionally,
the,
what was it like stories we want to create,
uh,
a companion site that lives on,
I'm from driftwood but feels like it's its own thing also.
So that if you want to only look at what was it,
like stories,
you can go there and all their stories are presented it in this way.
Like a single,
like Pearl has six other stories.
So a wave,
just watch that one story we just watched,
but know that there are other stories from Pearl right there that you can just
click on next.
Uh,
so yes,
we,
uh,
we need help with website development and that story map.
So reach out.
Yeah.
Did I answer your question?
Okay,
great.
Um,
I also want to know that the,
um,
Googlers to are either watching this video or here in the room,
uh,
can in their own personal capacity outside of work,
certainly offer their stories to I'm with drift away,
then we're happy to help connect,
uh,
you know,
you as volunteers and with Nathan in order to get those stories up,
if that would be something that would be of interest.
Does anyone else have any questions for Nathan while we're here?
Yeah,
Raheem Vito,
mind just popping up to the mic so we can capture you.
He needs an,
my name's a quick question.
So you said,
so you,
um,
wholesome times onsite events of to help with the cause was,
and also how did you,
how do you decide like what type of help,
like build community,
you know,
where did you go for those resources or do you just kind of develop that
yourself or,
yeah,
we basically just,
um,
kind of kick.
We knew that we wanted to take it offline.
And we,
you know,
we've been operating for nine years and we know that we have a lot of supporters
and fans,
uh,
because whenever we have fundraisers,
people show up.
So,
but that eliminates a lot of the rest of the community who,
who likes I'm from just would,
if you have to pay $100 to go to,
uh,
a fundraiser.
So we wanted a,
an option for anyone to participate,
uh,
in come in and be part of the iron from trips with community.
So all of our community events are free and typically they're at a,
they're like happy hour times at bars and more generally a community spaces.
Um,
and so that we,
uh,
and later in March,
we have a,
our anniversary party at stonewall upstairs,
uh,
in April we have a storyteller spotlight at club coming.
So,
uh,
you know,
we're trying to have,
target different age groups and different people in the community just by having
fun events.
And really it was,
it was,
uh,
it also,
we have like just last week I spoke at Cuny here in New York and they have an
LGBT student group,
so some are college campuses,
some are like at bars and community centers.
Uh,
we had an event at the center several years ago.
So yeah.
So really the,
the objective was to take it offline and get all these people who know about I'm
from driftwood if they gather in a room as opposed to just commentate on
Facebook or whatever.
Okay.
Yeah,
I see.
You're saying Leslie,
so how do you keep them coming back?
MMM,
it depends on what it like people to go to the events,
um,
our newsletter and good like,
you know,
drink specials at the bars and you know,
but really we had an event,
the last one that we had,
um,
featured,
his name was Robert Richards and he just had,
it was a,
what was it like storyteller?
It was one of the most incredible experiences,
like seeing him watch his stories.
He had seen them and we published it over a year ago.
So we got to see him.
Watch his own stories.
And at one point he was like,
he was like,
wait,
stop.
It was about a former lover.
And uh,
he was like,
stop,
I can't,
I can't.
And then the moderator asks him questions and he had talked about it and he's
like,
okay,
I'm good.
Let's finish the video.
Finished it.
And he was like,
that was just,
you just have this emotion and like raw emotion in the room.
And I think that's what gets people really coming back.
They see the,
um,
the emotions that come out from these stories and also seeing the story teller
there.
So for the storyteller spotlights,
it's just this powerful experience to witness and to hear stories in an
interview from our elders,
you know?
So,
uh,
so the,
my hope is that that people,
the people who go to these experience,
that this,
these feelings and come back for more.
So thank you.
Thanks Ray.
Any other questions?
Anyone brave?
But I can see out there.
Um,
if not,
then thank you so much for being here.
We're so delighted to have,
I'm from driftwood here at Google and to be able to hear about the process and
the journey for you,
um,
and also how we can get involved.
So we will definitely look forward to seeing you again,
but really appreciate it.
Let's give him a round of applause.
Shall we
thank you.
Yeah,
thanks.
You wanna play the third video.
Okay.
We've got it might as well.
We've got it.
It's right here.
My name is Alexa SB now and I'm from New York City.
I recently came to Mississippi,
uh,
four months ago to teach.
I'm teaching middle school art,
sweat,
teach six through seven.
I'm six,
seventh and eighth grade.
It's been eight weeks now.
And it was interesting being a young person,
right?
Because I'm obviously very young and coming from New York City and then
asserting this kind of power and being in this place where you are not really
connected to the culture plus like I don't necessarily,
um,
I am a colored person but don't racially identify with.
They still don't know what I am and trying to,
where were you in the state?
It's kind of very black and white and the inbetween between is strange and for
students is hard for them to gauge that.
So it's my second week of school,
I'm still figuring out how to navigate this new realm that I'm in,
right?
This new place,
um,
new position and I have to walk all the students in a line to the bathroom.
So there's some waiting time and as other students are using the bathroom is two
kids.
These two students break out in a fight,
kind of,
not a fight,
but just like a tiff between the two.
And they're like,
you're gay,
you're gay.
And I was just like,
how do I address this knowing that if I can get fired for being gay in
Mississippi,
which is like a huge thing.
Um,
and then on top of that,
knowing that there's like this like religious thing,
how do I then say anything about it?
But I knew that had to say something,
something needed to be said.
So I was like,
we're not going to speak about being gay in a negative way cause it's not
negative and we're not going to use that word in that kind of way.
We're not going to use that language.
And this one kid kind of straightened up,
looks forward and he's like,
okay,
I'm not going to do.
And then this other kid,
this other student blurts out,
well no,
it's a sin.
Being gay is a sin,
it's wrong.
And I didn't know what to say at that point and
I just knew that I couldn't push too much,
especially it's my second week.
Like I'm not trying to cause like huge waves either and I was just kind of like,
well we're not using that word in a negative way and kind of just shut it down
there.
Um,
so he just straightened up and we ended up going back to the classroom.
Time passes on and I still hear it every now again the hallway.
And the first time I saw maybe like a small light was this one kid decided to
say it in my classroom.
The word comes up again.
And these two boys start saying,
you're gay,
you're gay.
And all I did was give a look and this one student says,
we're not using that type of language.
And I was like,
yeah,
that's amazing.
And I'm planting a seed and it's,
it's something's happening,
right?
So there's a,
there's going to be change and she's going to take some time.
I think it's important to always respect where people come from and understand
that everybody has a different background,
has different beliefs.
Um,
and so the only way to really create any type of change is to meet them where
they,
where they are,
meet them with what they know and try to not change the way that they think,
but maybe change the framing of what they've seen,
especially when you're dealing with young students.
Right?
Um,
so by not reprimanding him in a kind of way of saying like,
you're wrong,
just saying that's just not the,
that's not the word to use.
We're not using that word in a negative way.
And that word isn't negative.
And hopefully students will feel a lot more comfortable.
Any students that are maybe struggling with sexual identity,
that they can see that they can come to me.
I'm an ally.
I'm someone that
they can speak to.
That was a nice way to end.
Thanks everyone.